[Music]
hi I'm Mike at Roskam here at cube Con
in Copenhagen and I'm here with Craig
Peters from J frog how are you I'm doing
great how about yourself
great so tell me a little bit about what
G frog does sure so J frog is a
repository manager and platform for
enabling software developers to
collaborate effectively across
distributed teams with all the different
package types they use all the different
tools and do it in a way that safe and
allows software to be delivered faster
to any end point what do you mean by way
that's safe how does that work with
containers oh that's a really great
question
so glad you asked it's as though we
staged or practice this yeah we didn't
so what I mean by safe is that when you
deploy an application into any
environment so let's take kubernetes is
an example why would we be talking about
that here but if you're deploying to
kubernetes you have meant you might have
packaged your application in helm right
so you might have home sharks that
you're using to deploy the application
those depend on docker images right
those docker images you know where they
are they're in some sort of secure
registry how do you know what's in those
containers so what Jake frog artifactory
provides we call it the kubernetes
registry the kubernetes registry of
artifactory allows you to have in one
place the source of truth for all of the
data all of the package types all of the
dependencies that have been built into
the container image and then packaged
into a home targeting used to deploy the
application you can use any other
packaging type it doesn't depend on home
but essentially we act as a docker
registry that understands all the
dependencies so you know where things
are and then as a repository manager
what that means is that you can create
different repos for different teams at
different stages of development
lifecycle so I have a different one for
my app to app app testing you know
exactly exactly dev QA production so
production can only read from production
repositories and then you know you don't
want to duplicate all those things we
essentially have a promotion model so
based on you might want to make it from
one registry to another or something
like that actually automatically and
it's one we like you want to make it so
only service accounts can do that and
then you want to make that completely
independent of the underlying storage
and use any off mechanism right that's
that's what we do and do you want to
talk me through what's happening right
here absolutely so the story here is
that you're deploying an application
that's packaged as docker images inside
a home chart to do kubernetes right well
what's in it it's docker images if you
look at an image it actually is usually
layers all right we use layering and all
that that consists of your application
whatever code you've written maybe it's
a maybe it's maven right you might have
written Java and use a build tool or it
might be MPM and you know you've got
that bit you've got the packages you
dependent upon which are like external
packages you might have operating
systems so the idea from left to right
is that using a common registry
framework you can manage exactly all the
way to the lowest level and that's
actually really important for companies
that where the software production life
pipeline is their production and you
can't be blocked if you have an issue
getting to the public npm for example
right you keep that and that stops
people in reality and so what we do is
we create what's called a virtual
repository that sits on top of your
local repo and the remoted repos that
you have a local cache of and that
allows organizations to have really good
control over what packages go into their
applications so tell me about graph is
and how our sorry tell me how how Jay
Froggers with Professor graffities
Google's open source metadata image
server and you were one of the launch
partners for that back in October how
does that how does that work together
absolutely so one of the things you have
to do in this kind of a scenario is you
have to have a really deep understanding
of the metadata about all of the
different package types graph a is is a
open API for exchanging metadata about
those assets between many different
systems a lot of different tools in the
ecosystem will
different kinds of information about
those so the the first things we started
with obviously our vulnerabilities
everybody wants security and safety so
yeah so one of our products is called
x-ray and x-ray is a part of this
package and what it does is it has a
deep understanding of the layered
packaging it unpacks them all
understands the components that go into
a package matches them against
vulnerabilities but we also do licenses
and things like that the point of graph
fayus is that it makes it very easy and
lightweight to exchange information
between US and other graph AS data
providers so say google has a huge
database of different kinds of des like
maybe performance our compatibility data
you need a way to aggregate that in your
CI pipeline so that you can make
automated decisions about whether or not
something you know your software is
ready to move from staging into
production right and so you don't want
to have to go and query all of the
different systems x-ray provides way
using graph a us to aggregate all that
data into one system one call great well
thank you so much for chatting with us
that the floor at Keep Calm having a
good time here oh it's been great we've
had lots of great conversations and you
know the we're really glad to be here
and participating this community thank
you so much hopefully we'll see you in
Seattle and and thank you all for
joining and watching us here at cube con